حقيقه للامانه المصادر التي كتبت قليله
جدا فيها في هذا المجال يمكن الشيخ عبد
الرحمن بن رويشد والشيخ حمد الجاسر رصد
حقيقه العلم المناسبه التطرق انه انه
البيرق والبيارقيه اللي كانوا من الدوله
السعوديه الاولى والثانيه كان حقيقه يعني
من ابرصهم ببيت بنطوق سليمان بن سيف بن
طوق وابراهيم بن طوق وعلي بن طوق ومن
بعدهم حقيقه الحميد السلم هذا اللي اللي
مع الامام محمد بن فيصل في الدوله
السعوديه الثانيه في في معركه جودا كان من
شجاعه هذا الرجل ان ربط نفسه بالساريه كما
ذكر الشيخ احمد الجاسر في كتابه انه انه
يعني تشجيع للذات انه ما ينهزم لانهم مع
سقوط
وفعلا وهو قتل قتل في في معركه جوده ربط
نفسه يعني لتشجيعا لنفسه في كثير من
البيوت التي حملت الرايه يعني حتى من
احفاد
ابراهيم الظفيري
الى ان وصلت في عام 1906 عبد الرحمن بن
مطرف اوكل له الملك عبد العزيز قبلهم ال
معشوق حقيقه في عهد الملك عبد العزيز
اثناء خروجه من الكويت عبد اللطيف المعشوق
حمل الرايه الى دخول الملك عبد العزيز في
الرياض وابنه منصور حمل الرايه من بعده
ومن ثم يعني حقيقه سلمت
اعتقد انه توفي في معركه البكيريه وما هي
المواصفات التي تتطلب في حامل الرايه يعني
المثل اللي ذكرته قبل قليل منتهى الشجاعه
الصراحه نعم من اهم الامور المتعلقه بحمل
الرايه ان الرايه لا تعطى الا حقيقه
صاحب باس قوي شجاعه حكمه
ذاب يعني قوه جسديه مع سقوط وللاسف يعني
يسقط الجيش كانه رمز ما ادري معنوي او
مادي
للدوله وعاده يتم اختيار البيارغي ان يفوق
من سواه من حيث
الحكمه والصبر والقوه الجسديه لانه ما
توجد في كل شخص